spider-man is the dream job of all time
is it not it's pretty great are you
afraid of getting typecast or are you
going to embrace being spider-man i i'm
embracing it i'm not really afraid of
being typecast anyways how long does it
take to shoot a spider-man movie
uh we shot for about five months but
there's a whole prep time and then all
the computer stuff afterwards takes a
while and what'd you do you do special
workout because when you finally turn
into spider-man you're muscular as hell
well how did that work how do you get
that size i worked out for five months
six days a week up to four hours a day
and do you eat more food when you do
that i had a nutritionist and i was
eating four to six meals a day
lots of protein no kidding
it is a dream job were you competing
with a lot of guys or was it just right
from the get-go you were going to be
spider-man uh in sam's mind i think uh i
was the guy but the studio
wasn't sold on me immediately and when
they weren't sold on you isn't it true
he went and shot some film with you to
prove to them that you'd be a good
spider-man it was a
a bit of a process but first we did
like an audition on videotape in a
little room and they got it took them a
couple weeks to see it were you insulted
um my ego was rubbed a little bit you
know i mean you've done enough work i
mean they could certainly rent cider
house rules or or wonder boys and see
how you act sure and yet they were who
did they want in the role who were they
suggesting i don't know i heard so many
names was all rumors as far as i knew
but this was the role you wanted i
wanted to do it and they saw the tape
and they said well we know he can act we
want to see him do an action scene right
so we did a proper screen test and i
wore a blue unitard
and uh you know the unitard compresses
your muscles so you uh
you couldn't see definition i was in
pretty good shape so i i peeled the
thing down and tied it off of my waist
and did the fight scene topless i
thought you were terrific in the movie
a great peter parker thank you you did a
great job because it's not an easy role
to pull off
you